au regard de l'actualité depuis un an
avec la guerre en Ukraine et toutes les
conséquences qu'elle entraîne dans
l'ordre mondial et dans la vie
quotidienne des Français notre
responsabilité la plus urgente et de
reprendre en main notre souveraineté
elle nous commande d'assurer à long
terme notre souveraineté énergétique
garant de nos libertés lors de l'accord
de Paris l'engagement a été pris de
limiter l'augmentation de la température
moyenne de la planète en dessous de 2
degrés par rapport au niveau
préindustriel tel doit être l'objectif
qui nous réunit au-delà de notre bord
politique concrètement cet engagement se
traduit par une maîtrise de notre
empreinte carbone à environ 2 tonnes de
CO2 par an par français d'ici 2050 nous
y sommes encore loin notre empreinte
carbone est actuellement de 8,9 tonnes
par an ainsi pour arriver à tenir cet
objectif les efforts à entreprendre sont
conséquent la politique des petits
gestes n'est pas suffisante et nous
avons besoin d'une politique
volontariste en la matière en train de
respecter nos objectifs climatiques au
niveau du groupe démocrate nous
partageons la double exigence de la
nécessaire sobriété et de la
décarbonation de nos modes de vie la
sobriété et la mère des priorités mais
ce ne doit toutefois pas être une
sobriété sans technologie ou sans
innovation ni une sobriété qui menace
nos libertés individuelles d'autre part
une part incompressible de nos activités
nécessitent une consommation d'énergie
notre deuxième priorité est donc de la
décarboner pour ce faire la fin de notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles et
l'électrification de nos usages sont
indispensables il en va également de
notre souveraineté économique face à
cette double exigence sobriété et
décarbonation nous devons collectivement
nous donner les moyens pour réussir nos
objectifs climatiques et les solutions
ne se comptent pas par milliers c'est
dans ce cadre là que le groupe démocrate
accueille favorablement ce texte relatif
à l'accélération des procédures liées à
la construction de nouvelles
installations nucléaire et au
fonctionnement des installations
existantes il est la continuité de
l'action engagée depuis 2017 par le
gouvernement afin de se doter de tous
les outils pour remplir nos ambitions
climatiques je souhaite ici rappeler la
ligne politique du groupe démocrates sur
le sujet du nucléaire nous sommes
Proclima nous ne sommes pas dogmatiques
et nous avons bien conscience des
difficultés et interrogations légitimes
que pose le nucléaire mais nous sommes
pragmatiques sur les différents
scénarios proposés par RTE ceux qui sont
exclusivement composés d'énergie
renouvelables présentent bien trop
d'incertitudes quant à leur réel
achèvement aussi il est nécessaire
d'avoir une part de nucléaire dans notre
mix énergétique au sujet du fond de ce
texte nous nous accordons sur le fait
que l'extension des sites nucléaires
existants doit être facilité au maximum
le temps industriel étend suffisamment
long pour que les délais de construction
ne soient pas rallongés en raison de
difficultés administratives les mesures
proposées dans ce texte auront des
effets sur des délais de mise en service
et en conséquence sur le coup des futurs
réacteurs pour résumer notre ligne
directrice demeure l'accélération des
procédures partout où cela est possible
sans jamais rogner sur nos exigences en
termes de concertation et surtout de
sûreté sur ce dernier point il est une
chose essentielle que nous devons
souligner l'examen en commission de ce
texte a été marqué par l'adoption d'un
amendement réunissant les compétences de
l'Institut de radioprotection et de
sûreté nucléaires avec celle de
l'Autorité de Sûreté Nucléaire notre
groupe n'a pas apporté son soutien à
cette mesure au stade de la commission
regrettant en manque de temps et de
concertation et s'interrogeant sur la
pertinence de réussir les missions
d'expertise et de recherche avec celle
de décision au sein d'une même structure
la capacité d'écoute de Madame la
Ministre face à nos vigilances a permis
un débat apaisé et rationnel dans le
cadre à présent de l'examen de ce texte
dans l'hémicycle notre groupe propose
par voie d'amendements la création d'un
comité de suivi de cette réforme
proposé de parlementaires afin de
veiller à ce que certains principes
soient respectés parmi lesquels le
maintien des compétences la séparation
des expertises et la garantie d'un
dialogue et d'une bonne information à
l'égard de la population pour conclure
ce texte ne sera vraisemblablement pas
l'unique occasion de parler du
développement du nucléaire en France
cette année nous avons également la PPE
qui arrive cet été mais il n'en demeure
pas moins que l'étude de du texte est un
signal fort envoyé à la filière du
nucléaire en France avec lui il écrit
notre volonté de retrouver l'outil et la
culture industrielle nécessaire à la
réussite de grands projets nucléaires
afin de lancer le chantier industriel de
ce siècle il est nécessaire d'avoir une
cape un cap une vision et une
détermination claire le groupe
démocratie est engagé et notre main ne
tremblera pas en votant en faveur de ce
texte